Okay.
So as we said were,
most of the lectures nowadays are about
carbonyl chemistry and in particular
today we're going to talk about
[inaudible] means the nitrogen analog of a
carbonyl group and ina means, which
you'll see are closely related to those.
And then get onto the general topic of
oxidation reduction and how it applies in
organic chemistry. And in its simplest
case where it involves electron transfer.
In the unlikely event we have any time
we'll review Nmr a little bit at the end.
Bear in mind, this isn't on the exam
Friday, but it will be on the final.
Okay. We talked last time about
a ketone going to an mean.
So you have an amine, it's unshared.
Pair is a nucleophile to attack Pi Star,
put a proton, then I'll take a proton
off the nitrogen onto the oxygen minus.
You get this carbon Ola mean,
and then the unshared pair
allows you to lose hydroxide,
right?
So you get this cad ion and a minium
ion protonated amine and hydroxide,
but the hydroxide can take
the proton away. Okay?
So that's how you make emotions.
And we mentioned that last time.
The amine is the nitrogen
analog of a carbonyl group.
Uh,
the n the equilibrium constant
for this, however, is unfavorable.
It lies toward the starting ketone,
but there are some cases
where the equilibrium lies
the other way. For example,
with Oih as the r group,
it lies toward the right that's called
an oxy or when this complicated thing is
used as the amine,
the equilibrium lies to the right and
that's called a two four Denitra fennel
hydra zone or a two four d n p derivative.
And these things were really important
before Nmr came along. And, and,
and I are to allow you to characterize
compounds because you had these,
these, uh, uh, ketone liquids
typically that were very difficult to,
to, uh, to deal with.
But if you treated them with hydroxyl
amine at the top or two for die nitrile
fennel hydrazine at the bottom,
they created the AUC seem or
the two for DNP derivatives,
which were easy to crystallize and
gave nice sharp melting points.
So there were tables of all different
ketones and what their oxygen's melted at
and what they're two, four d
and p derivatives melted. At.
So you've made a couple of these
derivatives beige or their melting point,
and then you knew what ketone you had
if you didn't have Nmr to help you out.
So these were very important and you'll
see that that such, uh, compounds,
this kind of in mean is important
in, in, uh, biology as well.
Now,
why do these equilibria right?
Lie to the right when with an
[inaudible] group at lies to the left.
Okay,
so let's think about, we have an
unshared pair here on the, uh,
on the group that's attached to nitrogen
where we don't have an unshared pair
here. How might that help the
equilibrium lie to the right?
How might it stabilize the products?
The fact that you have an a mean which
has a Hetero atom with an unshared pair
next door. What special stability
might you get on the right from that,
that you wouldn't get on the left?
Anybody got an idea?
What's good about this compound?
Having an unshared pair
here attached to the Amine,
Matt,
you got an idea?
Sure. You got the Pi Star here
and it can overlap with that.
So you get special stability on there,
right? It's uh, it's our Lilly, the,
the unshared pair is adjacent to
the, uh, to the, uh, double bond.
So you got special stability on the right.
Now how about on the left does heavy the
unshared pair on the left to make any
difference that would help
the reaction go to the right,
right.
Is there any reason it should be unstable
to have that unshared pair adjacent to
the nitrogen on the left?
Hmm.
Bear in mind that the nitrogen
itself has an unshared pair.
What if they overlap
right?
If you have to occupied orbitals
come together, they mix up and down,
but up more than down the unshared
pairs repel one another, right? So the,
so it's unstable on the left because
of the overlap of unshared pairs.
So both of these factors shift the
equilibrium toward being stable as,
as it means as oxy or two for
dinitrogen mental hydra zone. Now,
there are other cases where, uh, it
means a very important, for example, uh,
in the olden days when, when it was
difficult to separate compounds,
uh, it's still can be difficult
to separate compounds,
but there are a lot more techniques
nowadays with fancy chromatic graphic
techniques for example. But
Gerard developed this, uh,
this reagent which is you see one of these
things that has an unshared pair next
to the nitrogen, so it'll make a
nice strong in mean a stable, I mean,
and it could be reacted for example,
with a ketone in cortisone
or a steroid hormone, right,
to make it soluble in water.
So without Gerard's reagent t it
would be dissolved in, in, uh, in,
it would dissolve when you
do an extraction it would
be in the organic layer,
but if you add Gerard's reagent,
it goes into the water layer.
So you can separate it from other things
that would go into the one or the other
of those layers.
How does that work?
Why does you ards reagent make
the ketone soluble in water?
What,
what's the nature of the polarity?
It's more of that polarity
polarity is having,
is having something to sty polar
plus here on minus here, right?
It's much more so than that.
This reagent has a charge that
you can't get rid of, right?
Cause there that nitrogen has for Al Keel
groups on it so it can't lose a proton
and get rid of its charge.
So once this is hooked on to here,
the molecule is permanently
a cad. I am, right?
So then it dissolves in water.
It's like a cat, a cat, ionic Emmy,
a hydra zone. That is the hydro zone
is those things that have nitrogen,
nitrogen, double bond, right?
Carbon. Okay. So there's a,
there's another example
of the importance of Ibi.
Now you remember this slide that you've
been reviewing for the test about,
about chromophores, but let's just now
focused on this part down at the bottom.
Notice that it's the end mean that holds
the Chroma for the thing that's going
to be colored that conjugated system
onto a protein to make Rhodopsin.
So that's what holds Retina Aldehyde.
This was originally an Aldehyde
with an oxygen on here,
but it get formed and [inaudible]
and got held to the protein.
So it functions the way it's
supposed to do in your eye. Okay.
It means are also important in
the synthesis of amino acids,
particularly in the,
in the uh,
an originally in the technique developed
by out off Stryker. Stryker was,
uh, was a student and an
assistant in a later in, um,
in leaving slab in Giessen we
talked about last time, but in 1854,
he figured out how to make the amino
acid alanine by starting with acid
Aldehyde, reacting it with moaning
fluoride and potassium cyanide.
Now let's figure out how that happens.
First to react,
the ammonia of ammonium chloride,
which is an equilibrium of course
with ammonium chloride, uh,
with the Keith with the
Aldehyde to make an mean. Okay.
Then what's going to happen next do you
think given the reagents you have there,
another reagent comes in,
the reagent that comes in is cyanide.
What we'll sign cyanide I do with an Emmy
cyanides and an ion a nucleophile.
It's a special nucleophile cause
its nucleus like at carbon.
So at carbon has a high homo on that,
then cyanide.
So where's it going to attack Cassie?
The Pi Star are the,
I mean it would also attack the ketone
if you had the ketone there. Okay.
So the cyanide comes down
to tax the amine, uh,
that makes a negative charge on the
nitrogen when you formed a bond.
But you could put a proton on there,
right? So you get this compound,
okay, now it that, that's the first stage.
Then you add strong acid and heated up
hydrochloric acid and water and heat it
up.
Now you protonate the nitrogen,
the unshared pair on the nitrogen with
the acid and now water can attack the the
cat.
I had to give this and lose a proton.
But now notice you have another sort of
him being like thing, carbon, nitrogen,
double bond. And we already know that
that can react with water, right?
To deliberate ammonia. We look, the
very first step was the same reaction,
going the opposite direction,
taking the carbon neo off,
putting the nitrogen on to make a new me.
Now we put an oxygen on,
pulled the nitrogen off,
right? And that's Alanine.
So he was able to make that
in 50 to 60% yield this way.
So such a high yield from VF,
such very simple compounds,
suggests to a lot of people that this
could be involved in the origin of life.
There are people who get into,
into discussions and debates
about how life might've begun.
One thing you need is amino acids.
This could have provided amino acids
without any, uh, extraordinary,
uh,
requirements in terms of starting
materials and complicated mechanisms.
Okay.
And notice as in passing here that
this is an important thing that our c n
triple a night trial,
carbon nitrogen triple
bond gives our COO h.
So you could make carboxylic acids by
first using carbon as a nucleophile
because the carbon is an ana,
the cyanide is an anti.
And so it can displace a haylight
do these other things, right?
And then you can change it into a,
into a carboxylic acid group.
So that's a handy thing and synthesis,
which is exemplified here. Now,
it's not only in the laboratory that
this kind of thing happens where you go
through any of mean here's an imaging of
being used in a biosynthetic scheme to
make the,
to make the amino acid glutamic acid.
So it's the same deal as before.
You have,
you have ammonia and you have Nadh,
which we talked about last time we talked
about in terms of nuclear affiliate,
aromatic substitution.
Okay.
And of course there are enzymes
that control this whole thing.
L glutamate dehydrogenase is that
is the one that does it. Okay.
So first the ammonia reacts and gives
the mean and then the [inaudible],
then, uh, uh, uh, then you, uh,
protonate the nitrogen.
So you have a car,
carbon cad ion,
and now the Nadh gets into the act because
you remember Nad h was nad plus two,
which h minus had been added. If you
go back and review that, you'll see it.
So it can, it can go the other way too.
It can give up h minus and make Nad plus.
So now the h minus can come down
in the tack that carbon, right?
And you have glutamic acid.
And this is not for mammals
and essential amino acids.
They don't have to get it in their diet
because they run this scheme themselves,
right?
So they make it,
they make it inside themselves
using El glutamate dehydrogenase.
Now that's an interesting, uh,
name for the enzyme that does this.
Because notice what we've done is that
the enzyme using the Nadh actually
hydrogenated this, it puts h two
on a chair and a chair, right?
The first stage came in as a proton,
and then the key one came
in from up here as h minus.
But what you might call this,
uh,
Alpha Keto glutaric acid,
hydrogen A's, right?
The thing that does this,
why is it called dehydrogenase?
Because a catalyst bakes,
the reaction go faster in either
direction and it was first studied in the
direction where it goes from bottom
right, bottom left to top, right, right?
So it's called dehydrogenase.
But the catalyst just makes the
transformation happen in either direction.
Okay.
Now,
once you have an amino acid light
glutamic acid that we got last time,
then you could make other amino acids
by what's called Trans Amination.
So you have a compound like this that
has a ketone in it that reacts with that
Amino Group to form an Emmy.
Right?
And then this thing ultimately comes apart
to go back to the alpha-ketoglutarate
Rick acid. So you sacrifice
having made glutamic acid,
having made this amino acid,
but you get back Alanine,
the one that's ch three here,
c h and h two
right now. What was the key step once
you formed this form? This [inaudible],
what had to happen in order to make it
unzip to make alanine and go back to the
Quito glutaric acid
notice in this first step,
we've made this double bond.
Obviously if we had the double
bond here and a single bond here,
then if we undid the double
bond by adding water,
we'd put the key tone at the
top carbon up here. Right?
And we have the a amino
acid at the bottom.
So what's key is to move the double bond
from here to here and the single bond
from top to bottom. Right. What
kind of rearrangement is that?
Can you think of a name for
a rearrangement like that?
Amy Did you say for
somebody said, Oh, I should.
It's an outlet for you arrangement.
All right, where are you? Say
Take off this, this proton,
which is adjacent to the double
bonds and put it on down here. Okay,
so that's called Trans Amination.
So again,
many other amino acids are not essential.
You don't have to get them in
your diet because you could.
There you have the enzymes that help
make it by transamination. Okay?
Now, does anybody recognize
what this fragment is?
It's a fragment of a much bigger molecule.
You know what the bigger molecule is?
Pardon me? I heard
someone say something, Dna
change the DNA. It's a bunch of, it's
here. Here's a stick diagram of it,
and it's a bunch of cs in a row,
okay?
But let's just look at that bit in the
middle there. All right, and let's, uh,
uh, break the chain here,
these phosphates. And uh,
and so we'll make these o's into ohs here,
right?
So there's the key thing
that's in the chain. Now,
there's an interesting
functional group there
that's called Hemi Ama.
Now that functional group,
so it has a nitrogen.
And an oxygen on the carbon.
Right.
Can you, does that remind you
of any other functional groups?
Yeah.
What would the oxygen
analog be if you had,
instead of the nitrogen and oxygen,
what would it be? Yeah, it
would be an asset towel. Right?
And you can see then you could take it
apart. The way you're taking an asset,
tell apart you have an haven't a carbon
eel and here an Nh when you would have
an alcohol and o h if it
were the oxygen analog.
So you have a sugar and the basis
it's called, right. But if that base,
we're an alcohol instead and
then reverse the reaction,
you'd make a key towel.
So the DNA is a whole bunch
of essentially key towels.
They're called Hemi aminals cause it's
at Ama now would be two nitrogens, Akita,
Alice, two oxygens, a Hemi am
unal is a nitrogen and an oxygen.
So you have a whole bunch of these
essentially key towels so that you know,
that's a protecting group for
a sugar. Right? So in a sense,
DNA as a protecting group for sugars,
although it has other uses as well.
Okay.
Now you can also get what's called Alpha
substitution via a really a relative
of, of the amine called INA mean. Okay,
so here we saw before you take the amine,
you've put it together to get the, uh,
m and l or the, the Carbon Ola
mean you have the unshared Perry,
you can lose hydroxide and you get here
and remember what happened before the,
Ooh, mine is took off a
proton to make an [inaudible].
Now you can't do that.
Can you see why you can't make an amine?
Why can't
you make an Emmy in here,
Chris?
The domain is the carbon nitrogen
double bond, but without the charge,
right? Cause you've lost the Proton,
but there's no proton on the nitrogen,
right? Because we've started
with a secondary amine,
one that has to our groups on it.
So you don't have the Proton to take
off from the ammonium ion, right?
But you do have that Proton on the carbon.
And notice that's in the Alpha
position adjacent to the double bond.
And this is very much like a ketone.
In fact,
it's very reactive because the n plus
makes that double bond even more.
Uh, even a lower Lumo the Pi Star, right?
So it's something that's going to be able
to stabilize and electron pair if you
pull that Proton off,
okay, so you, you do that,
the proton gets pulled off by
the hydroxide and you have this,
which is now called an Ian. I
mean it's like an Ian. All right.
Now you can make that in a 90% yield by
driving the equilibrium to the right by
removing the water,
which was the product you just made.
So you distill out the water,
then you can get a very high
a yield of this ina mean,
which it was shown to be a very
useful synthetic intermediate.
And the reason it's useful is the unshared
pair can get involved in making that
carbon nuclear fillic.
Remember we just said that cyanide is
an important synthetic intermediate
because it has a carbon
that's a nucleophile that can
attack another carbon form
of carbon carbon bond in the
striker synthesis of the amino acid.
We saw that, right? But here's
another one that can do, can,
can function as a nucleophile to make
new carbon carbon bonds. Uh, for example,
it can react with an acid chloride,
right?
So it adds addition, uh, association,
and then dissociation of the chloride,
right?
And puts an ACL group on the,
on the Alpha position.
Now you can bring water in,
right?
And reverse the formation of
the, of the, uh, ammonium ion,
right? And you get what you
see there is a Beta die ketone.
It's two ketone groups, not, not
adjacent to one another, not alpha,
but next adjacent with a carbon
in between a Beta die ketone.
So if you want to synthesize a Beta
die ketone, you can use this reaction.
And in fact, when our
is a c five chain, uh,
this was done in 70% yield. Okay? Uh,
that process is called stork.
Ina Mean Acla nation ACL.
Remember is our c double bond o.
So put our c double bond o on the Alpha
position of a ketone. So if you want,
you want the carbon eel grew up here,
you can do make the ENM mean,
then react with an ACL chloride.
Okay?
But that's not the only thing you can
attack with that carbon nucleophile.
You could attack RCL right?
Then that puts an art group
on the Alpha position, right?
Bring in water and hydrolyze
it and you get that.
And when our is fennel ch two Benzel,
there's a 50 55% yield of that
purified compound was obtained,
right? But that's not an
ACL elation that anymore.
You're putting our on not RCO.
This is an alkylation.
So this is called the stork eno mean ow
culation and there's a much fancier kind
of calculation that was done in
all these are in the same paper.
If you have an Alpha Beta
unsaturated key tone,
so a conjugated ketone right now you can
attack not just not the carbon that has
the double bond o on it,
but you can attack adjacent
to it right to the next,
to the terminal double bond there,
and then form this.
So it would form first that he analyte.
Then since the inlay could
be on the Alpha position,
Proton come in and you've
got that compound so you
can put that fancier Al Kill
Group on, uh, bring in water,
get rid of the helping group there.
And you have this dye ketone
now, um, this, these are called stork.
The reason they're called stork
is not because of the bird,
but because of Gilbert's stork shown on
the left there who was the phd adviser
of my neighbor. Uh, Fred
Ziegler, who teaches chem two 20.
Uh, uh, and in fact Storch
was a graduate or uh,
uh, Ziegler was a graduate student in
storks lab just at the time this work was
being done.
So when I went to talk to him about
getting permission to use this picture and
the slideshow,
uh,
he told me some lore about
it that I wasn't aware of
that I think is interesting
for you to know. So here,
remember that there's a lot,
there's an enormous amount of lord
that you just have to be around the way
Ziegler was around or to have used
these things in order to know.
So here was this, we showed this
70% yield of the free del Cra,
the stork, Acla Asian.
Right? But in fact, what,
uh, uh, Ziegler pointed
out to me is to do this,
you need to equivalence of the enemy,
not just one.
Now why do you need two equivalents
rather than just one mole per mole of the,
of the ACL?
Haylight because the first product,
remember before you got rid
of this helping group, uh,
from the Itam mean was that,
and that's a super
carbon steel group,
which means that that hydrogen is Alpha
both to this one and this carbon yield
group. So what property should that
hydrogen have? Unusual property.
Pardon me?
It's very acidic.
The anti on will be very
strongly stabilized, right?
So it'll be easy for it to
dissociate to give h plus right?
Now, can you think of anything
that would be a base in here?
Notice we identified the
INA mean as a nuclear file,
but nuclear files are also basic,
right?
So this product transfers a
proton to a mole of Edo mean,
right?
So that uses a second enemy and up.
So you need to have them if you want
to get the reaction to go. Otherwise,
the first half of the product chews up
the rest of the starting material, right?
But there's a cheaper way to do it,
which is to put in some other base
that can eat up the proton. So in fact,
they use triethylamine is
added in to soak up the h plus.
Okay. And that wasn't the only bit
of Lore Ziegler told me about, uh,
this, if you go to Wikipedia
and looked up, uh, you know,
me and alkylation, you'll get this
as an example of what the product is.
But in fact,
that's not the product.
The product is this in 71%
yield from doing this reaction.
So where in the world did that come from?
Well,
remember before we hydrolyze that it was
in that form a supercar video type of
group, right? And now here,
that carbon is Alpha to the carbon eel.
So you can make an eternal eight there.
So now this carbon and I n can
attack Pi Star at that carbon.
So you form a bond from here to here.
Now, of course, in order to reach,
you have to flop this over 180 degrees.
Okay?
So if you do that, then
you get this, right?
This is the new bond that was formed
to the carbon adjacent to the nitrogen,
right?
But notice with this,
you can make an anti in there. Take a
proton off. It's a, it's an analyte.
Where did the,
where would the proton go?
Okay,
go on the nitrogen here.
Right?
And now we have a leaving
group and a nucleophile
and that's the product, right?
Elimination from that compound.
So that's another bit of Lore that you
don't get. What? Wikipedia. Yeah, it's,
you get what stork founding in 1963.
Okay. Now, uh, that's what we want to say
about him means and now onto
oxidation and reduction.
Now this the most straight forward
kind of oxidation reduction oxidation.
Where did the word come from?
What does oxidation
originally who thought of
the term oxidation oxygen.
[inaudible]
the idea that oxygen made things acidic.
Shayla did,
yeah, Shayla discovered some of those
things, but the name came from France,
came to the blood loss.
His colleagues. Okay.
So oxidation was reaction with oxygen,
right?
Which made things acidic.
Where did the word reduction come from?
What's the reduced?
What does reduce mean?
Right?
Duco do Caray and Latin means to lead.
So to it is to lead back again.
So you've gone to oxidation,
you've put oxygen on to
something and then you reduce it,
you lead it back to what it was
originally, take the oxygen off.
When do you think that term originated in?
Where would,
where in technology would you be involved
in removing oxygen from some material?
It's very old.
Thousands of years.
You take a metal oxide,
treat it with a reducing agent,
carbon pull the oxygen, often make
CO2 and you're left with the metal.
That's how you get metal from metallic
whores iron for example. Okay.
So that's what reduces.
Okay.
But nowadays we understand that
in terms of electron transfer,
right?
To oxidize something is to remove
electrons from it to reduce it as to put
electrons on and that those actual
reactions occur in organic chemistry.
For example,
metals are something that are often used
as reducing agents like solid magnesium
and an owl keel.
Haylight can take an electron.
Where would the electron go
in Meth into methyl bromide?
If you took an electron out of magnesium,
where's the low Lumo Antonia,
right?
Darcy CBR. So we have reduction
sigma star. So an electron comes out,
we get out of the metal.
So the metal has lost, the,
has lost an electron and the
Ch ch three Br is gained one.
What will that,
how will that change the properties of
methyl bromide having an extra electron
in Sigma Star?
In what sense? Reactive. What
specific bond will change?
What do you call sigma star
one kind of more?
Well,
why do you call an antibiotic?
Because it usually breaks last attraction.
So what's going to happen?
So the Bob Burns,
alright, so you get c h three. Dot.
There were three electrons in that
sigma and Sigma Star. Two and sigma,
one in Sigma Star. So now those
three electrons or a pair on bromine,
bromide and a single electron
radical od on nothing,
right? Uh, now you can get, uh,
the magnesium Adam comes
out or May, uh, uh,
uh, and, and reacts with the,
uh, methyl radical to give, uh,
to give the methyl magnesium bromide.
And that's called the green yar reagent
and it behaves a lot like you might
expect ch three minus to behave.
It's a carbon nucleophile and it's a,
it's a strong base,
right? Of course. It's not really
ch three minus. It's actually the,
the, a sigma bond, the sigma
pair of electrons in here.
But because of the magnesium is
not, uh, is so high in energy,
it's orbitals.
This is an unusually high homo and we've
talked about it before and lithium can
do the same thing that magnesium did here.
Okay.
Green Yard got a very early Nobel prize,
not a 19 eight or something
like this because it,
because it was so useful to have
ways to make Al Keel nuclear files in
synthesis. Okay. 1912. Pardon
me. He got the Nobel prize.
Okay. Now another example is a ketone.
So you can, it can react with magnesium.
Now where will the electron
go? Roll. What are you saying?
What's the,
what's the low low low acid?
Put an electron in Pi Star.
Okay.
So now we can write that as a charge
on oxygen and the radical on carbon.
It doesn't break the bond because
there was a double bond to begin with.
So it's just the s but we went
down to a single bond. Now, okay,
now you can do that with another,
uh,
acetone on the surface of
the magnesium and get that.
And now you have magnesium
double plus between them, right?
But now since the two are
attached to the same magnesium,
the radicals can react with one another,
right?
To make a bond. And if you then add
water to put protons on the Ohs,
right?
You can get pinnacle.
And this is called the pinnacle reduction,
right?
And we've seen before that if
you treat pin a call with h plus,
you'll get Pinnock alone.
So here are two examples of
reducing an organic compound,
actually by electron transfer,
right?
But much more often in organic chemistry.
We're not talking about
actual electron transfers,
we're just using it as a
bookkeeping scheme right now.
What do we want to keep books about?
We,
we arbitrarily assigned
shared electron pairs.
We know from last semester the nature
of a bond and how electron pairs get
shared.
But for bookkeeping purposes,
we pretend that if there's a
bond between two different atoms,
it's an ionic bond and those two
electrons for bookkeeping purposes,
even though they're practically 50,
50 shared,
we assign them to the more
electronegative as the two elements.
There's nothing realistic about,
this is just the scheme for bookkeeping,
but it turns out to be
handy as you will see.
So let's look at these at these two comp,
these two at the ketone
and the alcohol here,
and let's figure out what the oxidation
states of the various atoms are.
Right? So let's start. Uh,
so we're just doing bookkeeping
here and I'll tell you why.
It's because it will be very helpful
in choosing reagents or remembering
reagents,
right?
Because we've classified reagents as
homos and Lumos and what they can react
with. But there's a completely
different way of classifying reagents,
not as having unusually high homos are
unusually low lumos or both or neither.
But you can classify them as to whether
they're oxidizing or reducing agents.
And a good reason. So you have
lots of, when you think of,
I need to make a transformation
from here to here,
I'd have to choose the reagent.
It could be very helpful if
you can exclude two thirds
of the reagents and think
only about the others,
or if you're trying to design a new
reagent to design it sensibly so that it
could plausibly give this transformation,
right?
So you can think about homos
and lumos would we do do that.
When we tried to think,
for example, for a ketone,
we'd think of having a high homo to attack
the carbon eel or a little Lumo like
a proton to protonate the oxygen.
That's mechanistic thought,
but we can throw out two thirds of the
candidates if we think about oxidation
and reduction. So that's why
this bookkeeping scheme is handy.
So let's look first at this carbon and
I'll get, I'll start you out here. Okay.
So this carbon has a bond to carbon.
Now that's a carbon carbon bond,
right? So one electron came from
the carbon. We're talking about.
One came from the other carbon,
but we now split it.
50 50 cents said the electronegativity.
So this carbon neither lost nor gained
in electron by forming the carbon carbon
bond. But it also formed
three bonds to hydrogen.
Now carbon is more electronegative
than hydrogen, right?
So those three pairs, each of them has
one electron that came from carbon.
One Electron came from hydrogen,
but for bookkeeping purposes,
we assigned them to carbon.
So now carbon has three electrons
that it didn't come in with, right?
It came in with four shared one with
another carbon bookkeeping. Keep that one,
but not the other one.
Made three bonds to hydrogen.
Get an electron from each of those so
that carbon has an oxidation state of
minus three is everybody.
See how we did that? Okay,
so if we see that,
now tell me what the next carbon is.
What should its oxidation State v
Roy
second car.
Then from the left.
Yeah.
What box does it too?
How many carbon carbon bonds.
[inaudible]
carbon carbon bonds.
Both of them split the electrons
since it's the same element.
So what should its oxidation
level? B. Z. Okay. How about the next one?
[inaudible] carbon
to bonds. To oxygen. Yeah.
And those electrons go to who?
Those went to oxygen.
Those two electrons of carbon went
to oxygen. So what's the carbon
plus?
Okay.
How about the next carbon [inaudible]
again, like the methyls on the left.
Okay, now let's look at the right.
That one's minus three. How
about the next one? Yeah,
that's zero. How do you, how
would you answer so quickly here?
Right? So that one zero.
How about the next one?
Zero.
Zero because it was minus one
with respect to the hydrogen,
but plus one with respect to the
oxygen. So it's zero. And finally,
now notice that almost all of these
were the same left and right. So we,
we're really wasting our time except
for getting some practice and doing
everything except the ones that changed.
So you look at the elements
that change their bonds, right?
To see what happened.
And if we do that now we see that only
this one and this one changed and it
changed plus two to zero.
So it got reduced.
Okay. So that question mark, now
we know is that's a reduction.
So we had to choose a reducing agent,
right?
So now if we had a way of classifying
reagents as being oxidizing or reducing or
neither,
then we would know.
We would only have to look among reducing
agents if we want to do this reaction,
unless the reaction might be a really
complicated thing where you do an
oxidation and then two
reductions or something like
that. But for simple things,
it should be a reducing agent.
Okay,
so let's try some elements are so some
compounds and see whether we would expect
them to be oxidizing or
reducing or neither. Okay,
so let's start with hcl.
There's a good reagent. Now,
what's the oxidation state
of hydrogen in this? There
it hcl. We'll see oxidation.
State of hydrogen.
Pardon me?
It's plus one
because it's sharing. It's got, it's
shared its electron with chlorine.
That means for bookkeeping purposes that
gave it to chlorine and so hydrogens
plus one. How about chlorine? Chris
minus.
Now, what would those be if
they were in organic compounds?
If they were attached to carbon,
what would hydrogen be?
If it were attached to carbon,
it would be plus one. What would
chloride be if it were attached?
Chlorine for attached department.
Okay, so these have there
normal oxidation levels,
right?
HCL has the same oxidation level for
agency L as as if they were attached to
carbon. So it's neither oxidized in nor
reducing if it goes into carbon. Right?
So that's neither. Okay. Okay.
Now let's take br two of Poli.
What's the,
what's the oxidation level
of bromine in br two and elemental girl,
I can't hear. Yeah, they're both zero.
They shared a pair,
but they get it 50,
50 for bookkeeping because they're the
same element. So they're both zero.
That one zero. That one. Zero. Okay. Now
what if they were attached to carbon?
What would they be?
Why this one
take electrons from carbon,
those atoms in bromine, right?
So are they oxidizing or reducing
the agents?
Is Br to oxidizing or reducing?
If it reacts with Carbon Carbon,
it'll take electrons from carbon
for our bookkeeping purposes, right?
So it's a reducing agent. It takes
the electrons away, right? It, it,
uh, uh, our part to say the wrong
thing. It's an oxidizing agent.
Okay. It takes electrons
away. Go ahead. It, uh,
it makes the carbon become plus.
Okay.
So B r two as an oxidizing agent and
we've already seen of course be to act as
an oxidizing agent. For example,
it reacts with ethylene.
What's the oxidation level
of carbon and ethylene?
Well,
what do you say in ch two ch two.
What's the oxidation
level of the carbon out?
Yes,
there are two bonds.
Carbon to carbon,
but those don't take electrons away or
give electrons. Right? Cause it's saint.
But there are two bonds to
hydrogen on each carbon.
Hydrogen done squat,
current bookkeeping,
we consider the bond
ionic for bookkeeping,
h plus c minus.
So the carbon got an electron from the,
from each hydrogen.
Right? So what should its oxidation
level via up the carbon on the left.
Okay. And same on there.
Right now we've, we,
we went through homos Lumos and so on
and saw how it reacts with how it reacts
with Brahmi. Remember Bro ammonium
ion bromide comes in and so on.
That's the mechanism.
But for purposes of oxidation
reduction there now minus a minus one,
right? Because the bromine
canceled one of the hydrogens.
So we went from minus two
on each carbon to minus one.
So if we want to go from ethylene
to die Bromo F to to die x ethylene,
right?
We need a,
we need an oxidizing agent like Vr to
not be our minus sodium bromide isn't
going to do it. It has to be
br zero. That's going to do it.
And he did an oxidized. Now
how about ch four? What's the,
what's the oxidation state
of carbon and ch four
Amy. Okay. That's minus four.
And the hydrogens are all maybe
plus one for each of
those, right? So those, uh,
now should that be oxidized? Reduced?
Well, certainly it, it, it reduces oxygen.
O Two,
what reaction do you call it when
you reduce a o two with methane?
What do you call it?
Call Fire,
right?
You got see co two and water.
Okay.
You can reduce Effie two oh three at
great heat. That's the original reduction.
Getting a metal from the metal oxide.
You can react it with br two and free.
Radical halogenation.
Right.
But generally methane is not very
reactive except under very special
circumstances.
It doesn't have a homo Lubo,
but we could classify it as a
reducing agent sensibly. Right?
Okay. How about lithium aluminum? Hydride
so this is assault l I plus,
right?
So lithium is in what state?
It's obvious plus one right now.
Aluminum,
aluminum, uh, is, is uh,
is forming three is forming
for bonds to hydrogen.
Now how are we going to do that?
Okay.
What we can regard this as is aluminum
plus three and one of the hydrogens,
hydrogens all being minus one,
right?
Except that we also have a
minus charge there, right?
So the aluminum would be plus four with
four hydrogens because hydride is more
electronegative than aluminum.
So the aluminum would be plus four
with respect to the four hydrogens,
right? But then there's an extra
electron. It's all h four minus.
So that we put on the aluminum
and we have a all three.
Now, uh, what is, what's an abnormal? Uh,
aluminum is a metal,
not very electronegative.
So we had expects the B plus try
[inaudible] plus three. That's reasonable.
What element here is unnatural?
That is not what it would be
if associated with carbon.
Yeah. Hydrogen. It's h
minus, not h plus. Right.
So that's going to make this a reducing
agent because of the h minus. Okay.
How about sodium hydride
there's an easier one,
Carl.
What's the oxidation state of sodium
in this plus one plus one and hydrogen
minus one.
What's unnatural?
Hydrogen.
So reducing agent. Okay.
How about potassium? Metal?
Nathan, what do you say?
What's it's 10 potassium metal.
What's the oxidation state of Gassy.
So you're okay.
Is that what it is with respect to carbon?
If you had a potassium carbon bond,
what would it be?
It would be plus wonderful. It's
carbon. It's less elected. I you
living carbon.
So is that an oxidizing or reducing agent?
No, it's able to give up an electronic
right to go from zero to one
plus one. So that's another
reducing agent. How about KCLS?
Hey, can help us with that. What's pay
plus one and chloride?
What are they with respect to carbon?
So where should we put it?
Oxidizing. Reducing or amazing. Okay.
Uh,
well,
our s s are,
what's the oxidation state of sulfur?
Sulfur is more electronegative for
these bookkeeping purposes than carbon.
Okay.
So with respect to that
sulfur carbon bond,
that it's more electronegative it
would be minus one. How about sulfur?
Sulfur bonds.
So your role, so what is it? The salt?
It's minus one.
Okay.
Same for the other one now.
Uh,
so that's an oxidizing agent because
of or associated with two carbons,
it would be minus two.
It would get an electron from carbon.
So as compared to, uh, so
as compared to our SSR,
right? O R S R it's, it's
a, an oxidizing agent.
So it oxidizes things like r two r s h is,
could be oxidized by tea,
can be oxidized to this by this.
So r s h is,
uh, is, is a reducing agent, right?
In that reaction and that reaction,
it's a reducing agent.
Did you ever see such a reaction?
Pardon me? Yeah, that's all fine.
Bridges are the permanent waves and hair,
right,
with exactly the reaction
that we talked about.
We talked about it then Homo Lumo terms.
But you know,
in order to make the dye sulfide bridge,
you need an oxidizing agent.
Something has to be the oxidizing
agent, and it could be this. Okay.
Uh, cro three. Uh, I think
I just have two more here.
Let me finish it. That's plus
six. Okay. That's minus two. Okay.
Now there's also a stabili unlike
this where it's cr plus four,
so cr plus six can become cr plus four.
That means it's an oxidizing agent,
cro three.
And we can put it over there. Okay. Water.
Those are the normal oxidation
level plus one minus two.
So it's neither except, uh, well, no,
actually let's, let's quit it here.
We can carry on next Monday. Okay.